moi
le seul
jamais
au centre on leur dit le monde
[Musique]
les plus l'originalité
messi
six victoires
mais là
si j'en sais
avatar a été accusé après
[Applaudissements]
ce sera très très près ils ont fait
montre que cette chaîne ont fait jamais
repasser tomas berdych iris et lundi on
est content m ais benhaim j'adore sa
tenue le manitoba sans rigoler mais
c'est ouf
si nous faisions des connaissances très
content de vous retrouver et aujourd'hui
c'est une journée un peu particulière
pour moi parce que c'est l'anniversaire
de celui mine de rien je ne m'en suis
jamais caché que j'aime le plus dans
l'excès c'est mon petit protégé celui
avec qui j'ai des barrettes lui avec qui
j'ai démarré c'est ce jury qui
déterminera il le sait c'est
l'anniversaire de noemi
[Applaudissements]
c'est de bon ton adversaire tu sais que
j'aime bien faire plaisir qu'est ce qui
te fait plaisir après un prime n'est
rien sans mal il avait un truc à retenir
je voudrais explique le sketch la pole
dance après je verrai omettre que tel
sketch de lui dire jean michel qu'est ce
que tu veux qu'est ce que tu veux
pourtant demirdjian verdière une
augmentation je veux dire d'un paquet
cadeau ou coadout & banking
mais un problème et après je disais
l'augmentation et tu sais moi tes trucs
[Applaudissements]
chez les obèses benhaim géraldine on est
à l'antenne à la chancellerie
je vous le dis on va tester une machine
incroyable aujourd'hui une machine qui
vient des états unis c'est moi qui vais
la tester je vous jure que c'est vrai on
nous l'a envoyé ce matin elle a été
testée aux états unis il ya deux jours
et on va être les premiers à la teste en
france je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
une machine très sérieuse c'est un
détecteur de mensonges rien qu'à la voix
c'est moi qui vais m'y coller voilà ça
veut dire que pour une fois très
reconduire pour tous à vous plaindre et
ça va vraiment bien ça paraît toute la
période où tout repose à toutes les
questions que l'on reçoit toutes les
questions et ville thomas aussi que va
me poser des questions vous verrez ça
dans un instant et franchement je dirais
toute la vérité de façon il y aura la
machine qui dira voilà si un truc qui va
pas bien voilà est-ce que vous vous avez
une vérité à dire comme ça voilà y'a pas
un courageux là il apparaît qu'il veut
dire un truc moi oui côté ça oui
je connais le mec qui a la plus petite
zigounette de steve et les chéri e
j'étais tranquillement chez moi cet
aprem je suis allé enregistrer à grandes
arcades samedi à l'est et à momo ya un
copain à moi qui m'appelle qui me dit
tiens je suis tombé sur un tweet ah
ouais je vais dire ce tweet tweet de
benjamin castaldi a sa méthode les ali
je suis chaud bouillant pour tpm paix ce
soir j'ai décidé de prendre ma revanche
contre cyril hanouna combat dès le début
de l'émission ça va être fou casta ça
castagne t600 sdf hashtag end hashtag
loser alors alors alors oui alors c'est
quoi bon bah ouais on va régler ça tout
je vous explique j'ai été faire des
examens pour mon genou
ouais bon il sauf que mon genou n'est
pas réparé complet ouais et alors besoin
d'un janot temps à cause d'une personne
oui qui a tapé dessus régulièrement
c'est qui ben non mais c'est ce que tu
vas chercher alors oui c'est ça tu es et
donc j'ai un ami tu veux bien me
remplacer mais notons début et tu vas
moins cher le faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
celui qui tape et ouais alors à
combattre et proposer un sujet bienvenue
cette idée là où pousse ou encore une
fois féraud tu veux que je leur dis que
je m'en occupe après non mais non frérot
je sais que tu es avec nous samedi soir
tu vas combattre je serai là d'ailleurs
samedi soir tu sais que je serai là pour
autant courage et ce avec une énorme
réunion de boxe et tu va défendre son
titre de champion du monde frérot je
suis très content que tu sois là je sais
que moi j'aurais castany voulais que tu
combat contre moi je sais que tu peux
pas combattre
à trois jours du combat et le jeu wii
mais moi je suis frérot tu vois pas par
contre toi lui se tenait devant soi le
second est à peine 10 mois comment juste
jouer savoir j'ai pas qu'on s'est dit
que ta plume c'est toi qui la paix à ces
micmacs et tapez donc te tais reconnu
tout de suite son numéro c'était quoi la
station numéro c'est quoi
[Rires]
c'est ça qui nous manque c'est une
énorme star tchèque ce fou de toi
ferrandis même si un boxeur exceptionnel
samedi soir frère je serai là je sais
que tu vas tout nationale nature est
avec nous faisait partie des missions
[Musique]
dites moi si tu te seras seul au milieu
de la foule qu'on peut rien n'avait
changé dans mon coeur tu es là moi
10 le mois de cette année contre oman on
a tellement déçu que tu étais d'avoir
mal c'est normal
on s'est tous plantés c'est
combien font nature
[Musique]
je serai dans la ville
un salarié
ça va ça vient
[Musique]
arrêté à ça
ça va
slimane dazi joliment mais a gardé les
commandes dès juin